our latest gimmick is we print
milk so milk alternatives yes so you
know Oakley oat milk in a tetra pack
and our slogan we flatten the milk
because we make this tetra pack
on the DIN A4 page so we send
you home 10 liters of milk
as a sheet of paper and that  You put it
in a mixer at home with water and you get exactly
the same result. It foams. It
tastes good. Our latest gimmick is we
print milk so no alternatives. Yes,
you know Oakley oat milk in a
tetra pack and our slogan is we make
the milk flat because it makes this tetra pack
we on the DIN A4 page so we
send you home 10 liters of milk
on a sheet of paper and you do that at
home with water and a mixer and you get
exactly the same result, frothy
taste